先生 私が無いというのは言葉としてはわかるんですが
私が無いというところから出発するか
私が無いを検証して確認してから
確認してもどうにしてもよくわからないんですが
それがね だから検証して確認するということは
修行して悟るということでしょ
悟って初めて私が無いことが発見する
だから私が無いということを発見することが悟りなんです
悟りの第一歩なんです
また三歩残ってますけど
だからそこっていうのはいつ来るかまだわからないでしょ
そこまで最悪人生するんですかとね
最悪で惨めで苦労ばっかりして
だから何のために仏教学ぶんですかと
だから すぐ今の瞬間から我々は一応気楽に楽しく幸福で
それなりに挑戦するものは成功もしながら生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから 二つあるということはまず理解して
今日から私が無いという前提で生きてみる
そうすると結構物事はスムーズに楽にいく
それで心の余裕も出てくるんだから
この私が無いというのは強引に前提でやってますけど
これはまあ証拠実証してみましょうというふうに
また同時に修行もしてみるということで
全面的に幸福になる道を選んだ方がいいんじゃないかなと
悟ってから幸福になる道を選んじゃうと
悟るまでが不幸なんですね
悟る前に一応ブッダの言葉を信じてもう前提作る
私が無いと あるのは因果法則だと
作って それに合わせて人生変えてみるんですよ
すべてうまくいくんですよ
そうすると 私が無いということは
どんどんどんどんこれが本当だということは実感出てきます
それ すごく修行する時は役に立ちます
まあ瞑想だけでもほとんど失敗するでしょうね
皆様方は これは強烈に私がいるということは証明してよと思っているんだからなんです
いくら言ってももう心は読んでますからね
私というこの自我がものすごい強烈なんですね
いつも競争的で見栄でやっちゃいます
それだったらもう悟りの世界とはものすごい違うんです
修行はすごく苦しくなるんです
だから瞑想は成功しない場合は
これは自我意識が強すぎるということなんです
だったら 日常生活の中でも私がいないという前提を入れておいて生活してみると
ものすごい気楽に合格します
ですから 今から私が無いという前提で生きてみる
でもそれはただのつけた前提だから
それは証明出さなくちゃいけない
いつか それもできるようになります
ということです 他ご質問ありますか？はい
ちょっと本題からずれるかもしれないですけど
精神疾患がほとんどが妄想に由来してるって話なんですけど
それとテーラワーダ仏教の国では
例えばその精神病んでる我々が見ていて
精神病んでる方を仏教的なアプローチで
例えば瞑想指導したりとか
そういうことってあります？ まずはこの最近経済状態と国の状況変わったんですけど
今まではまあ 0に近いほどなかったんですよ
その病気は ないっていうことではなくて
結構 0に近いぐらいでしたからね
精神的にトラブルがある人が生まれても
それは精神的な病気じゃなくて
ただ体の病気なんです
その場合は簡単に薬ありますからね
病院もあります そちらに行って薬もらって
もうそれで治っちゃうし
で あれこれやと妄想で対人恐怖症からこれこれとはないんですね
たまに女の子はいろいろヒス起こしたりはすることがあるんだけど
その場合ってみんなわかってますから
道徳厳しい世界だから
女の子の人だって年頃になっちゃうとすごく欲が出てくるでしょ
でももう厳しい世界だから親が怖いし
好きな男の子がいたっても
もうしゃべることも自信がなくてできなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで気持ち抑えちゃったところで
ちょっと頭がおかしくなって
それは大人がすぐわかるんですよ
その場合は わかってそこをなんとか女の子をね
ちょっとおだててあげて
すごいお祭りなんかしてあげて
祈祷と言うんですけど
本当はお祭りなんです
結構みんなに知られるようにして
そこでまあちょっと自信が出てきてね
で さっさと早く親がね
そびない人いるのかどうか調べて結婚させてあげる
それで終わり そういうことってのは
私の子ども頃でもよく結構そういうケースを見たことありますけどね
で 最近はいろいろトラブってる自殺する人々も出てきているしね
特にこのテロリストの世界では結構派手にあるんですよ
この愛から妄想の絡み合ってね
まあシンガル民族は何もやってないのに
もう自分たちが自分たちを殺していて
そこでタミル人もスリランカ人もすごいこのもう家族生活というかね
家族のあれ 何て言います
コネクションっていうのはね
ファミリーコネクションってのはすごく強いんですよ
外へ出しちゃうとなんか生活できないんです
結婚したっても 家族 2つまた別として一緒に繋げちゃうんですね
だからこの特にタミル人の場合は
この避難所やらキャンプやらね
そういうところで生活すると
もう結構自殺とかね 愛虫やらとかいろいろいろんな話は聞いてます
それで一般の人々は瞑想しているのかというと
全然ないんでしょう ないんです
その代わりにもう生まれた時から仏教の話を聞いてるでしょ
だから思考パターンは全部仏教的なんです
価値観は仏教的なんです
日本でも昔は多分お寺に子供の時から行ったと思うんですけど
今はもうなくなっちゃったんで
そういうことも一つの
いわゆるこの価値 我々価値観で考えてるでしょうし
だから自我中心的な価値観入れちゃうともう病気になりますよ
仏教の世界っていうのは
自我中心的な価値観じゃないんだからね
例えば果物の木を 1本植えても
どなたでも食べてほしいという気分であって
俺がそれを売って儲かりそうという気持ちはないんです
さて 売ることになっても
これは申し訳ない みんなに本当にもう美味しいものを食べてほしいという
それがもう自分の義務であるという気持ちあるんですね
だからこの思考パターンね
例えば昔は田んぼを作る場合は
一部は鳥たち 動物 虫たちにということでもう置いておくんですよ
それは稲刈りしない しかしきちんと面倒見て育てる
それはこれは鳥たちの分だと
そうなってくると病気になるわけないでしょうに
面白いことというのは
虫たちも鳥たちもそちらに行って食べるんであって
こちらに来ないんですよ
どういうことか やっぱりわからないそれは
だから農業やる人々はこれを食べる
みんなのために作らなくちゃいけないというふうに思っているんです
だから この無常との無常の考え方
お布施の考え方 みんな生命であって
輪廻でみんな苦しんでいるんだぞという考え方がずっとあるんだから
精神的に悩むということはないんですよ
だからいっぱい歌とかあります
この間 スリランカから来た歌の歌のグループが来て
その人が一つシンハラ語でわけのわからない歌を一つ歌ったんですね
単語難しくて いわゆるほとんど方言
方言というかね あって
彼がこれは昔 一般の労働者が歌った歌だと
でも あんた方は全然言葉はわからないでしょうと言って
言葉を説明してあげたんですよ
むちゃくちゃ仏教の距離なんですね
因果法則の話 業の話 無常の話があるんですね
それがもうものすごい
一般の労働者が自分で作った歌で
それを歌っているんですよ
ここまでできるのかと
えらい文学者にしたって難しいので
だから自然に出ている
その中にあった一つはこの
自分が牛舎でね 荷物を運ぶ作業なんですね
そこで牛を歌う 二行ぐらいでね
で 君もね 過去生でね いろいろ悪いことをしちゃったんだから
今はこんなね こういう苦しい羽目になってるんだと
人の荷物運ぶためになっているんだと
私にしたってもね 大したことないんだと
私もろくな過去で業してないんだから
こんな人生やと ですから
二人でこの山を登りましょうと
そこでこの山といえば
確かにその道で山があるんですよ
しかし 二人でこの山を登りましょうというのは
この苦しい人生を 輪廻の苦しみを何とか歩みましょうと
ふつつなげて歌うんですよ
それで牛に対して 自分の家畜動物じゃないんですね
仲間なんですよ あなたはたまたま業によって牛になったんですけど
私もたまたまこういう貧乏な人間になったんだと
ですから このブッダの真理がもうもう徹して
もう思考 言語 歌 何でも感でも入ってきてなってるんだから
もうこの苦労というのは全然もう笑っちゃうんですね
苦労に苦労を見て なんで俺がこんな風にならなくちゃいかんということはありえないんです
例えば対人恐怖症っていうのは
人は怖く感じることでしょう
みんな同じ輪廻の仲間と思っちゃえば怖く感じないでしょ
ですから このブッダの思考というのは
普通価値観として 普通思考の基本としてなってくると
精神病なんかはね もう
成り立たないんですね
妄想のせいなの とにかく
自害意識強ければ強いほど
妄想っていうのはもう強烈になるんです
で 私はいろいろ現代 自分の国っていうのはあまりわからない世界ですから
もう年も経ってますからね
世代一つですからね それでも行ったら客観的にいろいろ調べては見るんですよ
みんなどういう生活とかね
やっぱりなるほど変わってないなと思うところいっぱいありますよ
ある男の子がね もう親が愛虫でもう
ちょこっとした仕事はあるんだけど
もう自分で仕事しなきゃ給料もらわないし
1日の賃金でやってますよ
それで愛知で酒飲んでも寝転がっちゃって仕事に行けないでしょ
それでその日は収入がない
奥さんにももうどうせ仕事ないし国だからね
奥さんにもどうやって子供食べさせるかっていうことでもないし
その上喧嘩もするし 子供何人かいて
一人の子がもうこの生活は嫌ということで
もう家出したいんですね
家出したくたっても行くとこないんですね
だからお寺に来たんですね
家出したってもうやっぱり分
分ぐらいの距離なんです
[笑い]お寺に来たら
まあ村の子供たちだからね
定休日といったって意味がないし
行ったり来たり行ったり来たりだからね
でお寺に行って もういろいろお寺のことを手伝ったりできたりして
ご飯食べてどこかに寝てね
それはまあ状況は全部知ってるんです
父親はよく知ってるんです
まあ普通だったら父は恨む
憎しみっていうのはね
憎むっていうのが普通でしょう
で なんかいろいろ話しながら
なんとなく間接的に聞くんです
あんたのお父さん 私はだいたい同じ年ぐらいだから
私はすごいけなしてしゃべるんです
お父さんの あんたのあいつはね
どうですかねとかね 私は子供の時から知ってるしね
言うとやっぱり全然憎しみっていうのは一かけらもないんですね
ただ心配する ああいうものだったらね
早く亡くなるでしょう
病気になってね で 妹もいて
妹はすごく勉強できるんだったね
私が勉強できんだからねとまた自慢するんですね
俺は勉強できんだからね
でも妹はね よく勉強もできるしね
ということを聞くと やっぱり精神的に悩みないんですよ
それでもなんかあって
母親がね 私が寺にいるやつを呼ぶためには
十回ぐらい呼んでも聞こえない
誰かにあいつを呼びなさいと言わなきゃ
母親がもう寺に土地にも入らないところから一回呼んだとはもう聞こえるんですね
それで走っていくんです
で 母親が来て呼んだっていうことは
何か問題だっていうことまで知っているっていうね
で 親のこと心配するんだけど
自分にはどうすることもできない
それで私はいろいろ案内してね
でお前らは一人で生活しなきゃいかんそうとふざけていかんそうとか
いろんなことを それの話を聞いて真面目になっちゃったんです
で ちゃんと真面目に結婚もして子どももいますけどね
元気でやってますけど
やっぱり普通だったら最悪状態になるはずなんですけどね
学校に行ってないんですよ
もうどうせもう法律で行かなくちゃいかんだからね
もう八年間ぐらいは行ったと思いますけど
九年目までは難しいんですよ
かなり そこでもうやめちゃうんですね
で いろんなところのいろんな仕事を試してみたんで
どちらを試してみてもすごく気に入られるの
仕事はすぐ で まあ悪いことも喧嘩もするしね
喧嘩して警察のお世話になったことも何回もありましたけどね
一回お寺で何かどこかで喧嘩しちゃって
この喧嘩お寺まで持ってきて
お寺にまで警察を呼んで
私がいない時ね それ話聞いたらすごく怒鳴ってね
冗談じゃないんだと 何者と思ってるんだお前らはと
二度とそんなことやったら
お前らもう寺じゃなくて村にもいたものじゃないと覚えておけと
私を怒らせたらと脅しちゃったんですね
それからずっと私は口もきかない
もういてもね もうゴミ扱いしていたので一年ぐらい
それかなり厳しく聞いたみたいですね
ゴミにされたことは それから本人がまたもう生まれ変わったような感じで生活が変わって
で とにかく私はね まあ商売やりなさいとね
なんか商売がちょこちょこできるようになっちゃってね
それで資金をあげちゃって
ちょこっとしたあげませんよと
これであったらどうするのかというと
こいつはなんのことなく瞬時に計画を言うんだ
それだったら こういうこういうこういうこういうふうにやりましょうと
言ったら もう何の教育もないんだけど
もう瞬時に計画をできた言うんですよ
それでまあこの一年帰って
また私は帰りますからね
その間でお前ここぐらい成功してみせなきゃあかんよと言って置いてきたんで
今度行ってみ調べますけど
どこまで進んでいるのかどうかね
だからそれはもう明らかに仏教のおかげなんですよ
だからもうやっと幼稚園終わったぐらいのところから寺に来て勉強していましたからね
寺の似中学校には当然必ず来るし
もう来たってもえらい迷惑ですけど
あのガキの連中はね それにもやっぱりなんとなく仏教的な価値観から抜けてりゃいい方っていうのはもう体には入る
で 最悪の環境になっても
そこはなんとかもう乗り越えちゃうというかね
まっすぐな金持ちにはなりませんだけど
まともな人間として 村のそれなりの大人として生活できるようにはなります
いろんなケース調べてみたんですよ
一回かなり前 一回寺に行ったら
寺中もうもうもう平のところってあるなれば
もうむちゃくちゃ落書き場所どこにもない
本堂の壁っていっぱい
もう全部もう落書き それであの古い本堂があって
それはもう政府の高校学長からね
もう保存してるんですよ
それは我々はいじったりもしてはいけないし
こいつらその外の壁はいっぱい落書き書いて
そこで床も書いて デスクなんかはもう 二ミリぐらい置いて空けておけとはないんです
で これある時期なんですね
それ見てもう子供だから
相手はね まあどうにもならんしね
ちょこっとセメントでどこかに壊れたとこをちょこっと修理して直すでしょ
固める前に行ってそれに何か書いて逃げちゃうんですよ
それで永久保存になっちゃう
[笑い] で まず私は全部落書きをチェックしたんです
何書いているのかと この心の裏読めますからね
顔見えませんだけどね
言ってくれませんだからね
私が書いたとかね そしたらわかったのは
こいつら本当に正直素直にいい子たちやとね
いくらいたずら悪いことしたってね
心は汚れてないんだと何にも悪いことは書いてないんです
何一つ もう男たちやってるんだから
いろいろね 男の世界ではいろんな汚い言葉使ったり
いろいろあるでしょうね
全くない なんとか何とか書いてるだけで
まだまだもうもう見込みがあるんだよっていうことでね
そこで結構金かかったんですけど
全部綺麗にしたんです
全部もうもう壁っていうものあったらなきゃ書いてあったんだから
もう で もうくだらない
もう壊れかけてる黒板とか二つ三つぐらいあったんで
全部もうもうぬくるもうフレームまで書く
全部片っ端し綺麗にして
まあみんな集めた時 まあ仕事もそろそろ終わってきてね
まだ書いちゃうと困りますからね
ちょこっと一つ冗談言ったんですね
あの まあいろんなところで
まあこういう名前 こういう名前
こういうこととかね 書いてありましたけどね
それってどういう意味か
君知ってるんですか？君たちは
ったらもう誰も反応来ないんです
それは私が大馬鹿者であると自分で書いてることだから
これからも頑張ってくださいと
それだけ言ったのは ピシャッとやめと
それで一人一人が自分が何か落書き書いたら
自分書いたことというのをみんな知ってるんだから
それ自分でものすごい頭が悪いと表現したことになるんだと
もうどうにもならん 自分で言ってるんだから
それでもみんなもうプライド傷ついちゃって
きれいにやめたんですね
たった一言で そこでその波ももう消えたでしょうと思いますしね
ある時期は何かあったらすぐ壊す
こういうこれだったらとにかく壊していくんです
何のためかとわからない
スイッチとかあるでしょ
ただとにかく何とか入れて壊すんです
それも一回の言葉でやめてもらったんです
一番きつかったのはこのおばさん連中なんです
信仰深いんだからね もう明かりを伏せたら結構とこですからね
あっちこっち壁の上とかね
どこででもヤシの油入れて明かりつけちゃう
油漏れて漏れても セメントに油が滲んだったら
もうどうにもセメント壊れますね
お寺にはお金はない 修理修復するために信者さんもくれないし
相手がもう信仰深いおばあさんたちだからね
もう怒ったりどなったり
子供だったらもうこちらどうせ管理するんだから問題ないんだけど
これにどんな手を打った方がいいなとも考えちゃって
一応みんなで苦労して
それにはすごい苦労したんですよ
本堂の中掃除するとかね
ものすごく それにももう苦労して
すごく綺麗にして で 法事毎日毎日やってますからね
毎日来寺さんが来る 満月はかなりたくさん来る
その時は説法 厳しい説法じゃなくて
何か冗談ぐちぐち冗談言いながら説法したんですね
まあまあ 子供たちにね
いろいろ得のこと聞いたことないでしょとかね
例えばね 食事なんか人をね
誰でも言うんだからあげたらね
この 100回生まれ変わってもすごい幸せに生まれますよとかね
それで服を寄付する人にはこういうこういう徳があるんだよとか
知らないでしょとかね
冗談で言いながら ほら
知ってますかね お釈迦様に明かりを伏せたらどうなるんでしょうかと聞いたら
言葉ありますよ ディップドホーティチャックドとかね
で 目が現れますよ だからものすごい美しい綺麗な目がつくためには明かりを寄付するんだと
それを目っていうのは肉体の目だけじゃないんだと
すごく頭が良くなりますよと
仏教でチャックっていうのは知恵であって
目２つ両方ですよと これを覚えていないでしょうと言ってね
なんか冗談言ってるんですよね
それで知恵があればね
瞑想もできるし 輪廻の脱出するもできるし
どこいても知恵がある人は幸福ですよと
知恵が宝物ですと いて
これはね 明かり 1個をあげたらそれぐらいの徳があって
2個 3個 8個だったらね
すごい徳が増えるでしょう
当たり前です 言ったってもお釈迦様に応えるんだと言ってお寺の土地の玄関のところという
これ 100メートルぐらいありますからね
それよりはちょっとみんな出入りする見えるところに入れた方が
もっとみんなの役に立つのはもっと徳が増えますよと
まあやっぱり 本堂の中に明かりをつけた方がもっとみんなにやっぱりもっと徳が増えますよと
まあ一応もっと徳が欲しければ
お釈迦様のお手の上に明かりをつけたらどうですかねとかね
もっと徳でしょうと いきなりそれ言うんで
やっぱりそれよりお釈迦様を全部糸で布で巻いて油かけて火をつけた方が最高な徳でしょうと言ったんです
話はそれで終わり それはやめたんです
それから用意しているところで氏が明かりをつけない
それから言ったんですよ
本堂の中で三本に限ると
三本以上つけてはいかんと
三本以上つけたら何言うかと覚悟しておいてくださいと
それでやっと三本につけているんです
だから そういう言い方で
まあ冗談でもありながら
辛口でもありながら ものすごく厳しく言ってる全部混ぜて
だからそういう話は何のことなくできますよ
なぜならば まあ基本的にみんな論理型で仏教だからね
論理的に物事を考える
無知と馬鹿っていうのはとんでもないと知っている
だからそこら辺ちょこちょこっとけなしたら
もうギシギシともう直すんですね
だからそういういろいろ調べてみると
なかなかまだまだあの一番基本的なところはね
それほど崩れてはないところもありますし
無茶苦茶崩れてるところも当然ありますけどね
だからまあ大体ブッダの思考が人生論になってくると
もう精神病っていうのは縁のない話にはなります
PTSD とかね ヨーロッパから来て
津波のセクションではね
まあもうみんなにこの精神心理カウンセリングやるそうで
ヨーロッパ人が何カウンセリングするんですかね
仏教の人々にと私は思いますけどね
あの連中はものすごい元気だと思いますよ
うるさいほど 新聞であった記事なんですけど
このこの津波でもう大変な状態になった時は
この今総理大統領になっている人が総理大臣でしたしね
で その人の地方だからね
津波でやられたのは その人はこのお見舞いとか情報を調べるために行ったところで
いろんなところで行って
みんなと喋っていて 状況を調べたりして
どこかでもう外で船が壊れていたんで
腰をかけてみんなのお話やらいろいろ聞いていたんだそうですね
そこら辺でなんかじっとしてると男の子が来て
じっと総理の前に待っていて
で その子の親 両親も亡くなっているんです
津波で また兄弟も誰か誰か亡くなっていてね
この子だけ残っているんです
落ち込んだりとかそれはないんですよ
これそれでも 総理大臣はえらい大人とかね
もうすごい真面目な話してるでしょうにね
復活をどうしましょうか
どういう問題あるで 一番緊急なものはあれだなんでしょうかとかね
その子が総理大臣の方に行って
あのね 一体私はどうなるんですかねと聞いたそう
いいの？だから相手が総理大臣だからないんですよ
もうあの子にとってはただのおじさんですよ
対人恐怖症になるわけないんです
できれば話しかけて 誰でもいいんだからね
言ったら総理大臣どうなってるの？と聞いたらね
いきなりもう君はね 心配することはないでしょうと
ちゃんと面倒見ますからとね
ただ もしここら辺でね
うまくいかなかったらね
私は君をあの大統領官邸やりますから
そちらに連れて行って育てますからと
心配するなよと 私がもらう育てますからと
何かあったらと 言ったということを新聞で出てやったんで
それ読みながらね あれほど最悪な状態になっているのに
口だけ達者な子だなと
話聞いたところで 私ももらいたくなったんだからね
だったら俺がもらったっていい子だなと思ったんですよ
元気いっぱいで これなら私がもらいたいんだと
どういうことですから
まあほとんどないと思いますけどね
だから PTSD とかね
まあ例えばまあこんなのは人間にあるものや
仏教そういうことでしょう
不幸っていうのはもう当たり前に回ってくるものやと
これは予測してくるわけないでしょうと
計画立てて不幸になるわけないでしょと
突然でしょうね 不幸っていうのは
それにキャーキャーというものじゃないんだという教えですからね
しかし 人を助けることは大変徳ですよと
だからもうみんな助けるんです
こういう国々ではね もう対人恐怖症などなどね
いろんなことなんですけど
私たちの場合はバスなんかはね
大体まあ手ぐらい入れば随分空いてると思った方がいいんです
手が入るぐらいスペースあるんだぞとかね
そんなもんですけどね
それでもガチャガチャ文句言わない
みんなよく喋りますよ
お互い知ってるか知らないんです
そこでそのバスで目的地に行く間では
みんなお互いにどう元気ですかね
この頃大変ですねとかね
昨日はね あの米の値段が上がっちゃってね
10円で冗談じゃないでしょとかね
そうやってもう喋っても
喋らなかったらすごくおかしいんですよ
みんなよくもう顔を知ってる
知る必要ないんです ご挨拶はなし
自己紹介なんかあれって何やと
知らないそんなことは
ただもう仲良くしゃべる
だから形式的なおまじないとかすごく難しいんですよ
もう初めからギャーギャー喋ってますからね
初めの話終わりがないと
もう すごく大変です 私だけかもね
いくらかヨーロッパ的にぴしゃり時間で始めて時間で終わるっていうことをやっているのもこうで
法事とかはね もうごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ何時までも続きます
もういつでも時計見ながら秒単位でOK上げる時にはいつでも計算
時計を計算しているんです
で ビシッと時間に割って
はい 終わりました 終わりっていうとサッと出ている
弟子たちに言ってるんだから
みんなジジッと全部もう肩すいて電気消して
だからもう若者みんなもう出て行かなくちゃいけないんです
外の電気だけみんな出て行くまではつけてるもんです
そうでなきゃ昔 子供の頃は大人の何か法事があったら大体まあ12時になってもまだいるんですね
2時  3時になってくると
まあなんとなく一人二人って出て行き
やったかというとほとんどやってない
法事のそれも あと説法なんかあるって言ったら
じゃあ八時に説法と一応決めてるんですけど
大体8時だったらまあ始まるとか 10
時半は早い方なんですよ
8時の予定の説法を10時半で始めたら結構早いんです
[笑い]それ全部壊しちゃったんです
で 普通あの人々っていうのはそういうもう性格なんですね
だからそういうもう人工的な脳細胞で
あの養老先生が言うような脳細胞で作ってる世界っていうのは
あんまりもう合わないんですね
お互いに穏やかに仲良く生きるというね
まあね 現代世界ではね
それそういうね 自然と一緒に生きるっていうことはね
もうできないところまでね
壊れて壊してしまったんですけど
ま それでもなんとか頑張って新しい方法を発見しなくちゃいけないんですよ
こういう現代的なね もう個人個人で自分だけ生活する世界であっても
人間らしく穏やかで平和で生きるためにどうすればっていうことはね
ということで 時間とんでもなく過ぎてしまいましたけど
じゃあ終了といたします
どうもありがとうございます
乾杯